Voiceover: In the last
video, we saw an egg
from our mothers fuse with
a sperm from our fathers
to form a zygote that
would keep replicating
and turn into us, if this...
Let's say this was the
sperm from my father
that fuses with the egg from my mother,
and then this zygote will keep replicating
and eventually turn into Sal,
and make a video about fertilization.
So how does that actually happen?
So now that this zygote has the diploid
number of chromosomes, and once again
they're referring to that as 2N,
where N would be the haploid number,
2N would be the diploid number,
and in the case of human beings,
N is 23, so in the case of human beings,
N is 23 and two times N of course
would be 46 chromosomes.
I have my full contingency
of chromosomes here.
I got a Y sex chromosome from my father,
X of course from my mother,
so I'm going to be a male.
And so what then happens?
Well now, through mitosis, this zygote
is going to keep replicating.
So it will, you know, after one,
so after one, and we're
going to go into the details
of the mechanics of mitosis,
but after one round of
mitosis, it is now two cells.
It is now two cells.
And I'm going to draw it, once again,
I'm not going to draw it at scale.
It's now two cells.
I want to make sure I have enough space
on my little chalkboard here.
It has two cells.
Instead of drawing all of the chromosomes,
let me just say that each of these,
in my nucleus, I still have 2N.
I have the diploid number.
So each of these two cells
that it has differentiated to
still have the full contingency.
That's what mitosis does.
It essentially replicates
the entire cells.
You have the same number of chromosomes.
And then this process is
just going to keep happening.
These two characters
are going to replicate,
are going to replicate, and so then
you're going to have, through mitosis,
and now you're going...
So this is another round
of mitosis right over here.
Mitsosis.
So they just keep duplicating themselves.
And each of these cells
have the full contingency.
2N, the diploid number of chromosomes
for, well, in this case
it's going to be 46
for a human being.
And then this process
is just going to keep happening.
So this process is
going to keep happening.
I'll do dot dot dot to
show that, you know,
a lot of this has been going on.
So mitosis is just
going to keep happening.
And so eventually you're going to have
thousands of these cells,
and eventually as we'll
see, you're going to have
millions and ten millions of them.
So let me draw them really
really really small.
There's a bunch of them there.
And each of them, each
of them are going to have
the diploid number of chromosomes.
They're going to have 46 chromosomes.
23 pair of homologous chromosomes.
So we now have a big ball of these here.
And these cells, some
of them are going to,
they're going to differentiate into me.
They're going to differentiate into
the different parts of my body.
So for example, these
cells right over here
might eventually,
they'll keep replicating,
but then it's them and their offspring
might eventually differentiate
into my brain cells.
These cells here will keep replicating,
and them and their offspring,
I guess you could say,
or the things that they replicate into,
might differentiate into my heart.
These right over here might differentiate
into my lungs, and of course
all of these eventually will differentiate
into all the different, and
they and their offspring
will differentiate into all of the things
that make me me.
And so you have a lot
more of this mitosis.
You're eventually going
to have a human being.
So let me just say this
is more mitosis going on.
Mitosis.
And now let me make an attempt
to draw a human being.
That doesn't really look like me, but...
Well, I have a lot of
hair, so that's my...
I have big eyebrows as well.
Still doesn't look like me, but anyway.
You get the point.
And so, and I'll try
to draw fairly quickly.
But this is obviously not my best
rendering of a human being.
But you get the general idea.
Nice broad shoulders, that's nice.
All right, so let me, let me...
I'm focusing too much on
drawing this human being.
Anyway, you get the general idea.
My stomach isn't quite that flat,
but anyway, you get the general idea.
So this, it'll eventually differentiate
into a human being.
These cells here in pink
eventually differentiate
into the cells in the brain.
These cells here eventually differentiate
into the cells into the lungs,
and obviously at this scale,
the cells are way too small to even see.
These cells differentiate into the cells
of the heart.
Now, I want to draw an
important distinction here.
Because most of the cells that I've just
depicted here that are
just a product of mitosis,
these are your, I guess you could say
these are your body cells,
or these are your somatic cells.
So these, all of these
cells that I'm pointing out
in your heart, your lung, your brain,
these are somatic cells, or body cells.
Somatic cells.
And so you're probably wondering,
well how do I eventually get these
haploid number cells?
How do I eventually get,
if I'm talking about a male,
how do I eventually get
these haploid sex cells,
these gametes, these sperm cells?
I'm talking about a
female, how do I eventually
get these ova, these egg cells
that have a haploid number?
And the way that happens
is some of these cells
up here are going to
differentiate into germ cells.
So they're going to
In the case of, and they're
going to differentiate
when I say into germ cells,
they're going to differentiate
into your gonads.
In the case of a female,
the gonads are the ovaries.
And in the case of a male,
the gonads are the testes.
The gonads are the testes.
And the germ cells in the gonads
or the cells that have differentiated into
being part of the testes and ovaries,
those germ cells.
So we differentiate
them from somatic cells.
So there are germ cells there.
Germ cells in your ovaries and testes.
They, through the process of meiosis,
they through the process of meiosis,
can produce the gametes.
So if you're female you're
going to produce eggs.
If you're male you're
going to produce sperm.
But this is through
the process of meiosis.
Meiosis you're going to produce sperm
in the case of a man,
and you're going to produce ova
in the case of a female.
And this brings up a
really interesting thing,
because throughout biology
we talk about mutations
and natural selection and whatever else.
And it's important to
realize how mutations
may affect you and your offspring.
So if you have a mutation
in one of the somatic cells here,
let's say in a skin cell, or in you brain,
or in the heart,
that may affect your ability to, you know,
especially if God forbid it's a really
dangerous thing like cancer,
and it happens when you're young,
before you've had a chance to reproduce
and you're not able to survive,
that might affect your
ability to reproduce.
But if this is happening
in a somatic cell,
it's not going to affect the DNA make-up
of what you pass on.
The DNA make-up of what you pass on,
that's determined by what's going on
in the gametes.
So a mutation, if on the
way to differentiating
into gametes a mutation happens,
so if one of these mutate
and then keep replicating,
so let's say there's a mutation here,
and they keep replicating and
they differentiate into the germ cells
the mutation is right over there,
then through meiosis that produces
some mutated sperm.
Then that would pass on to your, well,
that has a chance of
passing on to your children.
Because once again, it might not be
all of the sperm cells
that have that mutation.
It could be only a handful of the
two to three hundred
million of the sperm cells,
and so if that mutation
somehow makes it harder
for some of the sperm cells
to kind of function,
either fuse with an egg
or even potentailly
develop and kind of swim
through fluid, then it still might not be
the thing that makes it.
So mutations only affect your offspring
in the situation where those, the cells
in which they happen are
eventually differentiated
into things, into gametes that you will
pass on to your children.